[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD ABRAMS: Whenever
I give a talk at I/O,
I always ask to be first
thing in the morning,
because I know only the
most motivated, smartest,
best-looking audience comes.
Give yourselves a round of
applause for being here.
So we're going to talk about
building apps for the Google
Assistant.
If you know nothing about
building apps for the Google
Assistant you're
in the right place.
This is meant to be
an orientation talk,
to give you a sense for
what scenarios work,
how to accomplish it.
And then, hopefully,
at the end of this talk
we'll intrigue you to want
to drill in more and find out
more information.
So I'm Brad Abrams, and
I'm a product manager
on the Google Assistant team.
VERA TZONEVA: I'm Vera.
I'm on the Product Partnerships
team on the Assistant team.
ADAM COIMBA: I'm Adam Coimbra
and I'm a Partner Technology
Manager on the Assistant.
BRAD ABRAMS: So when Sundar
launched the Assistant at I/O
last year, he did
so for one reason,
and that was to build a
conversational interface
to all of Google.
And we wanted that to be a
single interface, regardless
of what context you're
in, what device you're in,
or what task you
trying to accomplish.
So the way we think
about the Assistant
is that, it's a conversation.
And it's a conversation
between you
and Google designed to help you
get things done, in your world.
And one of the
reasons I'm personally
so excited about
the assistant is
it builds on Google's long
history of creating ecosystems.
And that history
started, actually,
with Google search where we
created a strong ecosystem
between publishers and readers.
It continues with
YouTube where we
have a strong ecosystem between
creatives and their viewers.
And, of course, many of
you know, on Play, we
created an ecosystem
between Android app
developers and their users.
It's that exact same
kind of ecosystem
we're creating with
the Google Assistant.
And we-- that ecosystem is
enabled by a platform we call,
Actions on Google.
So you might be
interested in Actions
on Google, because
it enables you
to connect with a
whole new set of users,
in different contexts,
in different places,
everywhere the
Google Assistant is.
You can also connect
to your existing users
in new and different ways.
And finally, it gives
you an opportunity
to innovate in a
whole new computing
domain, this domain of
conversational interface, which
we'll talk a lot more
about in this talk.
So since we launched the
platform, in December,
we couldn't be more happy with
the variety and creativity
of apps for the assistant
that we've seen.
Whether you want to order a
pizza from dominoes or play,
name that tune a
song pop, you can do
a wide variety of activities.
But I want to drill in on
one in particular today
to give you the anatomy of
one of these assistant apps--
What's really--
how do they work,
what's really under the covers?
So some of you
may have noticed--
in addition to the Android
version of the Google I/O app,
we now have a Google
Assistant I/O app as well.
So, you're able to
say something-- talk
to your assistant and say, OK,
Google, talk to Google I/O '17,
and then the assistant looks at
all the ways it could possibly
respond, all the context, all
the possible different options,
and picks the very best one
for this user, at this time.
In this case, because the user
used the app name, explicitly,
I/O 17, then that's
like a URL, or tapping
on a shortcut on the desktop,
and it brings us directly
into our Google I/O 17 app.
The user here is the
assistant given introduction,
and then here is an ear con.
So an ear con is to the ear,
what an icon is to the eye--
it's an audio
distinction to help
the users understand that
there's a transition happening.
And then there's a
change in the voice,
and the icons change,
and there is a--
now there's a two way dialogue
between the Google I/O app,
and the user.
And that two way dialogue
continues, until either party
is ready to exit.
So that's how it
looks on Google Home,
but, of course, we knew we
were launching for phones here
at the event, so we
wanted to also make
it work while on the phone.
And there, you see it working
on the phones, suggestion chips,
and images, and whatnot.
In addition to that, we also
wanted to let you book seats.
Some of you may have
noticed some of the sessions
yesterday were kind of full.
You might note, you can actually
reserve seats to the sessions.
So we wanted to let
you do that transaction
as well-- to book a seat.
So when a session comes up-- you
can click the suggestion chip,
reserve a seat.
And if you click that, we
use our new seamless account
linking to have you
sign in, and then you--
even if you haven't created
account with just two taps,
you can go and
create an account.
Then you see your receipt.
And of course it's free to
reserve a seat, so that's fine.
And the transaction is complete.
So, actually, what
we're going to do
is walk through the end-to-end
experience of building that app
I just showed in this session.
I'm going to start off by
talking about the design
process--
how did we come up
with that app, what was
the design that went into it?
Adam then, is
going to go through
the hard-core development of
it-- both the natural language
understanding part, as well as
the transactional part of it,
and show you in code
how to go build that.
And then, Vera is
going to show how
to make that app discoverable,
how you can get people
to actually use that app.
Let's drill into design.
But first, do we
need design, at all?
I mean, these
conversational apps,
these assistant apps, I mean,
they're just chat bots, right?
It's text input, text
output, there's no images,
there's no forms to lay
out, there's no CSS to do--
do you need design, at all?
Well, consider a
very simple case.
Say we wanted to reserve
a number of seats--
a number of seats
at a restaurant--
how might we handle this case?
We say for how many--
look at the wide variety
of ways that a user
might respond to this query?
How are we supposed to handle
each one of these cases?
Well, the answer, of
course, is in the design.
But, what is the nature of
design for these Assistant
apps?
Well, Oren Jacobs' Upholstering
coined this phrase,
"Interactive Screenwriting,"
which I think
fits perfectly what we're trying
to build with these Assistant
apps.
When you build a
Assistant app, it's
kind of like you're writing a
screenplay, like for a movie,
or a TV show where
you're writing dialogue,
except you get to write lines
one, three, five, and seven,
and somebody you
have no control over
gets to write lines two,
four, six and eight.
And you have to use
that to come together
with a beautiful experience.
And to do that, you have to
pull together design elements
from two different
disciplines-- one
is the linear narrative design.
That's what we learn about
character, storytelling,
and dialogue from books,
TV, shows, and movies.
But, you have to merge that
with what we learn about
from interactive design--
what we get from games, and
mobile web app design, things
where we learn about creativity,
engagement, and retention.
So we need to bring
those things together.
So let's talk about
how we do that, here.
We looked at all of
our Assistant apps,
and we found out the element
that they had in common,
the ones that were--
got the most retentions,
they had a really
strong persona.
And so we wanted to
build that for our app.
So what we did is, we actually
thought about you-- what would
you might want out of the app.
We benefited from
having a marketing team
that we could work with, but
you don't need a marketing team.
And really sat down and
understood the brand attributes
and the design principles.
And from that we
distilled a style guide,
and this style guide helped
us write the dialogue
for our Assistant app.
There were actually several
of us writing dialogue,
and by actually having
a guide like this--
I mean, we literally
had a version
of this that we kept up while
we were writing dialogue.
It kept the persona
tight and crisp
even though different
people were writing.
So just to tell you, we also
wanted to launch for the phone.
So we needed-- we knew we
wanted both visual and eyes-free
experience, and so we
wanted to make sure we
had the similar content.
So, one Assistant, but similar
content, so the chat bubbles
are a subset of the spoken text.
And that's because we could use
suggestion chips, which we just
fell in love with as
an easy way to navigate
through your Assistant app.
Users didn't have to guess
at what our app could do.
We could put the most
prominent things there,
and users could zip
through very quickly.
We also found that a
visual description--
even in a very data
heavy app like this,
a visual description really
helped bring more life.
So, wow.
That was a whirlwind tour of
design for conversational apps.
There's way more to
be said about it.
I hope you'll take
an opportunity
to drill into more
of the sessions,
here at I/O about that, or
catch them on YouTube after.
But, I'm going to
turn it over Adam,
who's going to talk about
actually building these things.
Adam.
VERA TZONEVA: Thanks, Brad.
So I work on
Google's G Tech team,
and our mission is, actually,
to help developers and partners
like you, launch
on the Assistant.
So, I couldn't be more
excited to be here today
to show some of these
awesome new features
that we're launching,
and, hopefully,
motivate you to go
try it out yourself.
So a couple slides back, Brad
showed some really cool screen
shots of this Assistant
app for Google I/O that let
you reserve a seat and sign in.
And, today, I'm
actually going to try
to build it with you right now.
So let's look at some of the
steps that we took to do that,
and that you could try yourself.
So first, we create a project
on the actions console,
and this is kind of like the
home for the Assistant app.
We then connect a natural
language tool like, API.AI.
Now, we really like API.AI--
It's a world class natural
language understanding tool.
But if you have your own
natural language understanding
tool that's best in
class, you can also
connect that right to our APIs.
We then connect
a web hook, which
allows us to perform back-end
processing, business logic,
and connect to APIs.
Again, we like Node.js, but
you can use any web server.
Once you have all these kind
of basic integration points set
up, you need to test it out.
So we provide a web
simulator, which
makes it really easy to
do local development.
But it's really
important to always
actually test on a real device.
So, just by clicking test
in the actions console,
you can immediately try
it out on your Google
Home, your Android, or iPhone.
So once we have
all that done, we
want to enhance it
for mobile using
some of the visual responses
that Brad talked about.
So we can do that with
API.AI and with our web hook.
And then finally, we enable
that seamless sign in flow,
and the ordering
experience by integrating
with the transactions API.
But, wait a minute.
So once we've gotten
all this done,
how does it actually happen
that a user can say something
to the assistant, and
it triggers your app,
and all and all
the magic happens?
Well, let's take
a look into that.
So what happens is the
user says something
like, talk to Google I/O '17 to
their Assistant enabled device
like, Google Home.
And the speech is streamed
through to the Assistant
and transcribed as text.
The assistant then applies
natural language understanding,
ranking, it uses
our Knowledge Graph,
and it uses the user's context
to understand the user's query,
and realize that the I/O
app is the right service
to fulfill that request.
So it invokes the I/O apps
API.AI agent and the API.AI
agent understands it against
an intent defined there,
that you've defined.
It then calls the web hook
to perform business logic,
to talk to the I/O
API, and get some data.
And it formulates a
conversational response,
which is sent all the way
back through to API.AI,
to the Assistant,
and out to the user.
Cool.
So that's how it works.
And let's get into some of the
details of how we built it.
So we mentioned that the
Actions Console is kind
of like the starting point.
And we're really
excited about this.
We launched it yesterday.
And it's a really focused
way to develop and manage
your Assistant app.
So the three main
things that it does
is one, allowing you
to configure and set up
the metadata and the directory
listing for your Assistant app,
and branding information.
It then allows you to manage
the testing and deployment
process in a fine-grained way.
And then, once live,
it gives you analytics
so that you can track how it's
doing out in the real world,
with the real users.
Then we connect it to API.AI, or
another natural language tool.
So, in API.AI-- the kind
of main thing that we do
is, we define
intents and entities.
So intents--
basically, model user
queries so that
we can understand,
in a structured way,
what the user wants.
Entities are sort of
structured packets of text
that let us extract meaning
from the user's request.
So once we've gotten
these defined,
we can then write
responses to user requests
in line in the API.AI tool.
And so, now that we have our
kind of basic model set up,
we can use training in API.AI
to improve the dialogue model,
over time.
So the example, here, is
for the Google I/O app.
If the user were to say, what
Android sessions are there?
API.AI is going to understand
that that maps to the list
session intent, and it's
going to send a request down
to the web hook, and trigger the
list session function, there.
So let's look at the web hook.
Now again, you can build a
web hook using any web server
framework, but we like Node.js.
And we like it so much,
we built a client library
that makes it easier
to interact with.
So you can get that
just with one command--
NPM install actions on Google.
And, basically, we have
a bit of boilerplate,
and we have a handler for
this list session intent,
list topics intent.
And you can see there, all
we're doing is we're calling
the Google I/O API, getting a
structured set of categories,
and then formulating a
conversational response--
the topics covered are--
dot, dot, dot.
Now that all this
stuff is set up,
again, we want to test it out.
So we have this web simulator,
and it's newly updated
to provide an interface for
testing things visually,
and for testing a
voice-only environment.
And, again, it's super important
to actually test on device.
So just by clicking,
Test and Actions Console,
you can immediately take your
device and say, talk to my app,
and you're going to be able to
test it out, just like that.
So I'm going to go over
to my demo one machine,
and we're going to
actually try this out,
with the real I/O app.
So this is the Actions
Console, and we
can see it's already set
up with the I/O demo app.
We've got some app
information set up there,
which is basically
branding information.
And it's already connected
to an API.AI project.
And we can go edit
on aPi AI, right now.
And we have some
intents already set up.
We have a welcome intent,
which handles the case where
the user triggers the app.
We have the choose
session intent,
which lets the user get
details about a session,
and a couple others.
So I've been around
I/O, yesterday,
and I heard some
developers wondering what
the free stuff was this year.
So why don't we make this
app a little bit more useful,
and make it so that the user
could just say to their phone,
anytime-- hey, what's the swag a
I/O, and get a useful response.
So to do that, we would
just create an intent,
and we can call it, the swag
intent, and add a query--
what's the swag at I/O?
And right there in
the tool, we can
define a response--
it's a Google
Home and $700 in Cloud Credits.
Awesome.
And so, we just hit, Save.
We go to the Actions
on Google Integration,
and we click, Test.
And, just like that, we can try
this out in our Web Simulator.
So we say talk to, I/O demo.
And we have to log in.
And it invokes this app, and we
can say what's the swag at I/O?
And it's a Google Home
and $700 in cloud credits.
Awesome.
So, now that we have some
of the basic wiring set up,
we can talk about making this
work really nicely on mobile.
So go back here.
So to make it work
really nicely on mobile,
we want to add visual responses
with API.AI and with our web
hook.
So API.AI provides a built-in,
card-building interface,
and this is really nice.
It lets us easily define
cards and chips and carousels
and lists.
It also can then
send that request
down to the web hook,
which will enable you
to create dynamic responses.
So that's a really nice,
useful feature we've added.
Let's look at how we do
it from the web hook.
So there's two really
important things in this code,
that you see.
The first one is
that we're checking
whether the user has a screen.
So this is super
important, because we
need to be aware of the user's
modality of their contacts,
and tailor our
experience accordingly.
So, if the user has
a screen, we show
a rich card that's populated
with data about the session.
So now I can head back
over to the machine,
and show adding that
right into the I/O app.
Looks like there's a delay, so
heading back over to the demo
one machine--
great.
So we have this session
that han-- this intent that
handles the moment
when the user has
asked for information-- specific
information-- about a session.
So this is the,
choose session intent.
And what we can do is add
suggestion chips, right there,
with the API.AI
response builder.
So we add some suggestion
chips, and we'll
add that reserve a seat chip.
And we can add some others like,
next session, other topics,
and hit, Save.
Now to add that rich card
that's dynamically populated,
we need to turn over to the
web hook, and update it.
So this is the web hook
code, and, right here,
we have, essentially, like
a controller for our app.
So it has a pointer to each
of the intents in API.AI
that triggers a function
in the Node.js code.
So the choose session
intent is, here.
And we can see
that right now it's
just doing a very simple thing--
it's calling the I/O API,
and it's creating a
simple text response.
So we have that code that we
showed before prepared here,
and we can add it in.
And we're checking whether
there's screen output,
whether the user has a screen.
And if they do, then we
add a rich, response.
Otherwise, we can fall
back on this text response.
And my web hook will
automatically update.
And I can go and
update, and test.
Now we're heading
back to the Simulator.
And let's say I'm
interested in the,
What's New in Android session.
So I'll get this
rich card with a link
and with the suggestion chips.
So that was pretty easy, right?
So, the last part, then--
heading back into the deck--
is to add this
transactional experience
where the user can sign
in and they can actually
make an order.
So we are so excited about
the transactions API.
It released for
developer preview,
yesterday, so you can
start building with it now.
And really what it
does, is it lets
you accept purchases and orders
from your users, with your app.
And we make this a great
experience on the Assistant
with three main things.
The first is providing a
seamless, build-in experience
for sharing payments
and identity information
between the user and the app.
Once the user has sort of
gotten this information,
and approved the
purchase, we then
give you a way to reengage.
Because you've now sent
the user a receipt,
and we can send
updates to that receipt
that manifest as
notifications for the user.
So you can actually reengage,
and get the user back
into your app in that way.
Now to integrate
with the transactions
API there are five main steps.
So first, building out a
basket, or a shopping cart.
And this can be as simple
as a suggestion chip,
like in the I/O app.
Or, it can be as complicated
as a menu-ordering experience
with lots of different
choices and customizations.
During that cart
assembly process
you might need some
more information
about the user-- you
might need to know
what's their delivery address.
This lets you set price, and
service availability, etc.
So we give you an
API to request that.
Once your order
is all set up, you
need to propose it to the user
and get their authorization.
So we provide a
propose order API
that lets the user
preview what you're asking
them to buy, and approve it.
Once they've
approved it, you need
to confirm the order-- so let
them know that it's active,
and send them a receipt.
So we provide a confirm
order API for that.
So lastly, many
transactional experiences
require the user's identity.
And so we provide the ability
to integrate with an OAuth 2 web
server, and provide a seamless
log in flow for the user.
So let's take a
deeper look into that.
So many of you, hopefully,
are familiar with OAuth 2.
It's pretty standard.
And, basically, to set it
up with Actions on Google,
you go to the Actions
console, and you configure
the usual OAuth 2 stuff--
client ID, client secret,
auth URL, etc, there.
And that lets us know how
to talk to your server.
And then, in dialogue,
you call an API
to trigger the sign-in flow.
So you can do that from
API.AI or from the web hook.
Now once the user is signed in,
you want to propose the order.
So this snippet of code shows
a proposed order API call.
And what we're
doing here is we're
building a structured
order object,
we're populating the line
item with the session title,
we're saying the
price is 0, and then
we're calling to ask for
transaction decision API
to propose the order.
Once the order
has been proposed,
we get a new request saying hey,
the user accepted the order,
now you need to confirm it.
So this snippet of code
shows confirming the order.
And, here, we're building
a structured order update.
We say, hey, the
status is confirmed,
we provide a receipt,
and then we send it along
to the user as a receipt, just
like any other visual response.
One more time going
back to the machine,
and we're going to actually
add all this into our app.
So where we left off is, we had
this suggestion chip-- reserve
a seat, but we don't have
any way to handle it.
So we need a new intent
to handle the case
where the user taps that chip.
So we can create the
reserve a seat intent,
and it'll be triggered when
the user says, reserve a seat.
And then, what we want
to do is immediately call
the sign in API.
So there's just a
little bit of code
that we need to put into
API.AI to trigger that,
and we can just add it
here, and hit, Save.
So with that, we're
calling the sign
in API, which will
log in the user.
Now to make this
really work, again, we
need to hook up our OAuth
2 server to the project.
So going back into the console,
we can see how we did that.
So we have this Account
Linking section.
We can edit it.
And we see it's pre-filled, but
we have the standard stuff--
client ID, client secret.
There's a couple extra steps
that we take in our OAuth 2
server to make the
integration really seamless
and, it's easy to
do, and we highly
recommend everyone does it.
So, what do we have?
We have an intent to handle when
the user says, reserve a seat.
We trigger the sign in API.
But what happens when
the user signs in?
Well, we have this
intent set up that,
basically, passes that event
through to our web hook.
And what we're
going to do, then,
is call the propose order API.
Once the order is proposed,
and the user accepts it,
we get another request
to API.AI saying,
hey, the user accepted this,
you need to confirm the order.
And that comes through and is
matched by the handle order
intent, here.
That, again, is
just passed right
through to the web hook, which
calls the confirm order API.
And then we're done.
So the last thing to do
is just add this code
into our web hook.
So, going back
in, we see we have
the controller for our app,
and we have the handle sign,
and handled order--
handlers.
And we see that they're
empty, right now.
So we can add in that code.
So handle sign in-- again,
this should look familiar.
We're building an order
object, populating it
with session data, and proposing
it to the user, with this call
right, here.
For handle decision-- this
is where the user has already
accepted the order, and we
want to provide a receipt.
So we can add that code and it
should automatically update.
So that's it.
That's all it took.
And now we can actually test
this out on my demo two device.
Just have to update the project.
[NO SPEECH]
Cool.
So we're just going to go
over to the demo two device,
and we can say, I/O demo,
what's new in Android?
We can tap the
reserve a seat chip.
OK.
Well, that's why it's
a developer preview.
We can do one thing, and I
think it'll make it work.
Thank you, thank you.
We appreciate it.
So, I think, it will work,
if I can just do this.
Might have been user error.
So let's try one more time.
I/O demo, what's new in Android?
There we go.
Cool.
And we see with
just two taps, I'm
creating an account
on this server.
And we proposed the order to the
user-- what's new in Android?
$0, I approve.
And we get our receipt.
Cool.
So that's all it took.
We did that in
like, 10 minutes--
build a transactional
experience, seamlessly signed
in the user.
It's pretty awesome stuff.
So let me jump back in for just
a quick recap on what we did.
So we created a rich
mobile experience
for finding out
about I/O sessions.
We added a suggestion chip to
let the user reserve a seat.
And we connected
an OAuth 2 server
to enable a seamless
sign-in flow.
And finally, we used
the transactions
API to propose the reservation,
and get the users acceptance,
and send a receipt.
We did this, again,
in like, 10 minutes.
So I really-- I believe that
all of you could go, right now,
and add it and build
apps yourselves,
that do the same exact thing.
And I'm so excited
to see what you do.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it over to, Vera.
ADAM COIMBA: Thank you.
Thanks, Adam.
I'm, Vera, and I'm
here to tell you
how your app can be
discovered, once you build.
I have the opportunity to talk
to partners like you every day,
and this is one of the
primary things that we hear.
Let's actually
start by admitting
that we live in a pretty
amazing time in technology.
People are asking computers
to do things for them,
they're asking them to
help them plan their day,
to get from one
place to another,
and to even clean their
apartment in a mess.
And they're asking
for the little things
like, my little brother,
despite being 22,
recently asked the Google
Assistant how to make
scrambled eggs for our family.
And so, we know that
if you're building
a productivity app, or a recipe
app, or a smart home app--
your users are out
there looking for you.
And if there's one thing that
we've learned about discovery
over the years,
it's that the best
way to find users who
want your service,
is for them to find you.
And think about it,
this is actually
a very different world.
No longer does the
user have to know
that your app exists, or
have to download it, or even
have to set it up.
All they have to do
is say, OK, Google,
or long press on home
on their mobile device,
and they have access
to your service,
and that's on over 100
million, plus devices.
And, I'll be honest,
we're still getting
started, there's a
ton of work to do,
but that's a pretty
exciting thing.
Our goal at Google is to help
connect you to your users.
So, today, we're starting
with three primary ways
of enabling discovery
of your Assistant app
through the Google Assistant.
The first, is in
dialogue-- so directly
in the conversation
with the user.
The second, is through
the Assistant Directory,
which we announced yesterday.
And then, the third, is through
links that you can share.
So let's actually start
with in dialogue--
so directly in the
conversation with the user.
The most reliable
way that a user
can get to your Assistant app
is by explicitly asking for it.
Meaning, we have a set of
pre-established phrases--
things like, talk to,
speak to, ask, or at--
that once said, with the
name of your Assistant app,
we introduce you, and then you
own the dialogue end to end.
A user can also deep link
directly to an answer.
So to extend the demo
that Adam just did--
a user can say, hey, Google,
let's talk to Google I/O 17,
and then we introduce the app.
And they can also
say something like,
hey, Google ask Google I/O
'17 about what was announced,
and we'll introduce the app,
and then take the user directly
to the answer.
So some partner examples
of this are, hey,
let's speak to Domino's,
and then we introduce,
Domino's, and then,
Domino's comes in,
and you can order a pizza.
My brother might need this,
in case the eggs go awry.
Or, hey, Google,
at Akinator, and we
introduce a great
game on the platform.
Or, hey, Google--
I love this app--
ask, Dr. Doggy if dogs
can eat chocolate,
and we introduced
Dr. Doggy, for what
could be an urgent question.
The way to think about
explicit triggering
is very similar to typing a
URL and getting to a website,
or tapping on an app icon and
then going inside the app.
The next way to introduce your
Assistant app in dialogue,
is through implicit triggering.
So I'm really excited
about this one,
because this actually
starts showing
the promise of the platform.
We know that users are
asking the Google Assistant
a whole set of things.
They're asking, hey, tell me a
joke, or I want to play a game,
or I want to work out.
And we at Google look at all the
apps that can fulfill on that,
and suggest some to the user.
So this already works today.
You can say, hey, Google,
I want to work out,
and we introduce FitStar, which
has a great guided workout.
It's super easy to
be able to do this.
All you have to do is
add an invocation grammar
to your app in API.AI, or
whatever natural language
solution that you use.
So I want to show you
what that looks like,
because it's super easy.
So we're here in the
intent-- the swag intent
that Adam already created,
and you can see his,
what's the swag at I/O?
Let's say you want
to add something
a little bit more
colloquial like,
what's the freebie at I/O?
Type it in, you can
scroll down the answer
is still the same-- you
guys got a Home and $700
in cloud credits.
That's awesome.
Make sure the-- and the
conversation, you hit, Save,
and that's really it.
And you're able to test it
by going into Integrations
Actions on Google,
you make sure you
select the swag intent, here.
And then, once you
hit, Test, that's it.
We can do the test later, but
basically what happens is--
you say, what's
the freebie at I/O,
and then we introduce
the Google I/O '17 app.
Let's say you've never heard of
it before-- that's pretty cool,
I didn't know there was
an Assistant app that
is about Google I/O. And
then, the Google I/O '17 app
is able to say,
your freebie at I/O
is the Google Home and
$700 in app credits.
Awesome.
To go back to the slides.
One of the primary
questions that we
get about implicit triggering is
how are you guys going to rank?
We're going to be looking at
a ton of different signals,
and it's still very
early, and we'll
iterate on this
significantly over time.
But one of the primary
things we're going to look at
is the quality of your app,
as well as things like,
the user's context,
or their preferences,
and, again, we'll experiment
significantly, over time.
The next way for you to grow
discovery of your Assistant app
is through the
Assistant Directory.
So we launched
this with the goal
of letting a user try out
new apps, browse apps, as was
set the preferences for
their personal Assistant.
The way that a user gets to the
Assistant Directory on Android
is by long pressing on home and
then tapping the upper right
hand corner icon.
On iOS-- they get there by
going to the Assistant app
and then same thing-- tapping
on the upper right hand corner
icon.
And there's also a web
link for the Directory.
So once the user is
in the directory,
they can scroll
different categories,
they can tap on an app, they
can try the app directly there,
they can rate the
app, and then, they
can also set their own personal
preferences with the app.
So we have this concept
of voice shortcuts--
this is where a user can go
directly to your Assistant app.
So I have mine set as, hey,
Google, its chill out time--
and then Netflix starts
playing on my Chromecast.
And then, I have another one--
which I love-- which is, hey,
Google, it's party time--
and then my Phillips
Hue bulbs turn on,
and then, "Can't Touch This"
starts playing on my Google
Home device, on Spotify.
It's pretty awesome.
The way that you can improve
visibility of your app
within the directory is by
one-- again, keep the quality
of your app really, really high.
This is what's going to
help with both ranking
and with reviews.
And then, two--
submit rich images,
well-written descriptions.
This is what's going
to encourage a user
to try out your app
directly in the directory,
and then reengage with
it again in the future.
Cool.
The third way of growing
discovery of your assistant app
is through links
that you can share.
So you have a role here, too.
You have the ability to
promote and grow awareness
of your Assistant app.
We encourage you to do
this by doing things like,
one-- share through
social media.
Encourage your users
to take this viral.
Two-- promote through your own
owned and operated properties.
So link to your sites, or
to your Android or iOS apps.
Encourage users to
use your service
across different platforms.
And then, three-- encourage
press to drive traffic
to your assistant app, allow
other sites to link to it,
enable awareness that way.
So let's go to device
three, and I can show you
what that looks like, as well.
As I mentioned, you get
to the Assistant Directory
by long pressing on home, you
tap on the upper right hand
corner.
This is what the
directory looks like.
And we scroll down to
education and reference,
talk to Google I/O.
This is the landing
page within the directory.
You can hit share.
And let's actually tweet it.
And this is live,
which is awesome.
We can say, whoo, we're live
at I/O, and actually tweet it.
Cool.
Once a user taps on
that link, they go to--
directly to your landing
page within the directory.
Awesome.
Go back to the slides, please.
So as a recap, the way
that you can grow discovery
of your Assistant app is--
one, in dialogue.
So directly in the
conversation with the user,
both implicitly and explicitly.
Two, through the
Assistant Directory.
And then, three, through
links that you share.
So we know if you're
building a recipe app that
helps you cook breakfast
for your family,
or a fitness app that
helps someone keep
their routine your users are
out there looking for you,
and our goal at Google is to
help connect you to your users.
And with that, I'll hand
it back to Brad to wrap up.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome, thank you.
We've shown you a
ton of stuff, today--
building conversational
experience
for eyes free in the phone,
doing transactions, and getting
your app discovered.
You're now ready to participate
in our app development
challenges--
tons of great prizes.
I encourage you to do that.
But let's keep this
conversation going.
We're going to be at the
assistant booth, which
is kind of in the main
area, on the walkway there--
come by and talk to us
with more questions.
Ton of other talks.
And just a special things to
Sachit, who built the Assistant
app, that we see here today.
So again, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]